-Our next guest
is known as the Foodie Magician
and travels all over the world
performing magic, mentalism,
and comedy.
Please welcome Josh Beckerman!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-What's up? Good to see you.
-Welcome.
-Honored to be here.
[ Rimshot ]
Thank you for being here.
I'm happy to have you here
on the show.
It's nice to have you here.
Tell us about what you do
and why you call yourself
the Foodie Magician.
-Well, Jimmy, I literally eat
at restaurants all day
and all night.
I do not cook.
The only thing in my fridge
is bottles of water.
And when I'm not eating
at restaurants,
I do shows all over the world --
magic, mentalism, and comedy.
[ Audience murmurs ]
-Okay, good. Now,
I don't know what you're going
to do.
I don't know
if I'm eating something.
I don't know how this works,
the Foodie Magician.
Well, here's what you do.
My signature trick,
as the Foodie Magician,
is I have people think
of restaurants inside their mind
and I attempt
to read their mind.
So, what I want you to do now is
get a restaurant in New York,
anywhere in New York that you
like, that's it, okay?
-Any restaurant
in New York City?
-There's 27,000 restaurants
in New York, okay?
[ Cheering and whistling ]
So, do you have one in your
mind, yes or no?
-I mean, I feel bad for you.
I don't want to give you
a weird one.
[ Laughter ]
-Whatever you. Want.
-One is sticking in my mind.
-Okay, here's the thing.
Just so the audience knows,
we have not set anything up.
You have not told me a thing.
-Never.
-Okay, so, I'm going to start
saying stuff aloud, everyone,
to try to read Jimmy's mind.
What I'm saying out loud
could be totally wrong,
could be right. You're just
going to be poker face.
Don't shake your head.
It's going to take me
about 90 seconds to 2 minutes.
-Sorry.
[ Laughter ]
I have a hard time.
Oh, by the way,
one more question --
where are you from, originally?
Where'd you grow up?
-Saugerties, New York.
-That changes everything. Um...
[ Laughter ]
Okay, maybe you're thinking
about something upscale,
like Le Bernardin,
Daniel, or Jean-Georges?
Nope! Not my little Jimmy.
Not my little Jimmy.
[ Laughter ]
Maybe you're thinking
of something --
something Greek!
-Your little Jimmy?
I don't know what's happening.
What?
[ Laughter ]
Maybe you think
of something Greek, Jimmy!
Poker face, poker face, Jimmy!
Maybe you think
of something like Milos
or Avra, here in Midtown,
There's a nice Greek restaurant
on the Lower East Side
called Kiki's,
which is not too far away
from Wu's Wonton King.
Have you ever had the wonton
noodle soup at Wu's? It's ridic!
-Are you going to name
27,000 restaurants?
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Well.
-The show's going to end.
-Okay, hold on.
Maybe you're thinking
about Thai food?
No. Alright,
I'm going to go with this.
There is 27,000 restaurants.
There's one in your mind.
Can you focus in on the cuisine?
Do not say.
Think of the cuisine, okay?
You got the cuisine
in your mind? Look at me!
-Sorry.
-Look at me.
[ Laughter ]
-Over here. Over here, Jimmy!
I'm trying to read your mind!
-Sorry, sorry, sorry!
Yeah, I'm helping you.
-Okay. I'm going to go
with this cuisine, okay?
-Uh-huh, yeah.
-Maybe you're thinking
about Mr. Chow
for a little chicken satay.
Do you know the area
of New York this is in,
yes or no?
Do you know the area?
-I think so, yes.
-Okay, lock that in.
I'm going to go with this area.
Maybe you're thinking
about Nobu.
A little, little sush?
[ Laughter ]
-Sush? Do you abbreviate
everything when you say stuff?
Sush.
-Alright. 27,000 restaurants!
I'm going to go
with this restaurant.
One in your mind.
Are you thinking
about an American restaurant
in Gramercy,
called Gramercy Tavern,
yes or no, yes or no?
-No.
-Okay, that's fine.
There's 27,000 restaurants.
Obviously, it's not possible
to read your mind,
unless you're a mentalist.
Let me ask you this --
overall, what would you say
the cuisine
of the restaurant's
in your mind?
What kind of food?
-Italian.
-Italian?
What area of New York?
Would you say Tribeca?
Would you say Midtown?
Where would you say?
-Upper East Side.
-The Upper East Side.
Jimmy, out of 27,000
restaurants,
which one is literally
inside your mind?
Tell everyone.
Say it out loud.
-Scalinatella.
-Like this?
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Hold on a second, Jimmy.
Wait.
-How -- How in the world --
-You just got Foodie Magished
But hold on.
I'm not done.
Jimmy, listen to me.
Listen, to me. Jimmy.
-I just got Foodie Magished?
-Yeah, that's right. My --
[ Laughter ]
-He abbreviates that, too.
That's insane!
-Jimmy, listen, I'm not done.
I'm not done, because my shows
that I do all over the world
are actually about connection.
We're all -- Everyone
in the world's going --
We're all -- Give yourselves
a round of applause.
[ Cheers and applause ]
But I know...
-How did you get that?
-...that you and Questlove
are extremely connected.
You've been working
with each other for a while.
You guys are friends.
You guys are both big foodies.
So the question is this --
Questlove, do you also have
a restaurant on your mind --
yes or no?
-Yeah. Okay. Yeah, sure.
-I love the enthusiasm, Quest.
I love the enthusiasm.
-He's a hard guy to read.
He's a hard guy to read.
-Are you also thinking
about Scalinatella -- yes or no?
-No.
-Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
Wait, Jimmy, do me --
Let's try this.
You're at Scalinatella.
Look at me. Look at me.
And you want to order a dish
that's not on the menu,
a random dish.
Name a random dish.
♪♪
-Slice of pizza.
-A slice of pizza.
Are you thinking about
a pizza restaurant, Questlove?
Yes or no?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, that's cool.
What restaurant is in your mind?
Say it out loud
so everyone hears.
What restaurant
are you thinking about?
-Katz's Deli.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That legendary
New York City institution
in the Lower East Side
on Ludlow and Houston,
famous for --
What would you say the most
popular dish at Katz's is?
What would you say?
-Well, come on.
Pastrami sandwich or...?
-Pastrami sa-- Yes, right?
Pastrami sandwich,
which is very weird,
because on my way to the studio
tonight, everybody,
I picked up a little gift for
the number-one band in the game.
Give it up for The Roots,
everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
And that gift
is sitting right there.
Tariq, can you come down
and lift up that platter?
-[ Laughing ] Oh!
-That's been there
the whole time.
-T, come on.
-And can you tell everyone
what is under that platter?
-There's no way.
-Show it --
Lift it up and show everyone.
It's pastrami sandwiches!
-Whoo!
-The most popular dish.
But wait!
♪♪
-Yo!
-Wait.
Wait.
-Why do you think -- I'm sorry.
-Jimmy, I'm not done.
-Sorry. Why would he think --
-Because I also got you
a gift, Jimmy.
Because here's the thing,
everybody.
-Why would he think Katz's Deli?
-I have been dreaming about
this moment for a while now.
I had visions of everything
that would happen.
I knew that you would think
of a slice of pizza.
I knew Questlove would think
about Katz's Deli.
And that's why, everyone,
I got Jimmy
this gift of this painting,
of you and Questlove
eating pizza
outside of Katz's Deli.
'Cause we're all connected.
That's true.
And you just got
Foodie Magished!
-[ Laughs ]
-Thank you.
-Come on.
Got Foodie Magished!
-You just got Foodie Magished!
-I got Foodie Magished!
This is my man, Josh Beckerman.
The Foodie Magician.
More "Tonight Show"
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.
Wow.